now one of the assumed byproducts of
this announcement is that it could
derail or somehow Short Circuit the
house investigations that are ongoing
and then complicate any possible
impeachment inquiries but today the
house oversight committee released a
statement reading in part the Biden
justice department is trying to
Stonewall congressional oversight the
committee will continue to follow the
Biden family's money Trail and interview
Witnesses here now is the chairman of
that committee James Comer a congressman
David Weiss I know you wanted to bring
him up for questioning at some point in
the near future
how is that going to work now and don't
you foresee his saying uh not now and
not until the investigation is complete
right well this is another example of
the Department of Justice stonewalling
and obstructing our investigation I've
been complaining about this for months
but yet we continue to deliver evidence
that shows of massive Biden wrongdoing
and more evidence that shows Joe was
right front and center and this from day
one what this does today it protects
David Weiss he's from coming in front of
the committee which is fine this is an
investigation about Joe Biden I don't
think we need any more evidence to show
that the Department of Justice is trying
to obstruct our investigation I think
Merrick Garland made that argument for
us today we're going to continue to
follow the money we're going to continue
to interview witnesses that we know have
first-hand knowledge of what exactly the
bidens we're doing to receive the
millions and millions of dollars from
Bad actors in Bad countries around the
world and what role Joe played in this
game and that's what's important to
every American what role Joe played in
this game because we believe that we
have the United States that's
compromised because of the millions and
millions of dollars his family's taken
in
now Congressman um Dana Bash over at CNN
mentioned you today when discussing the
Biden 100 Biden probe and the
connections to Joe Biden himself watch
so far there is no evidence James Comer
the head of this Committee just told my
colleague Jake Tapper yesterday pretty
much admitted that they don't have
evidence to show that Joe Biden did
anything wrong
Congressman your response to that
pretty much didn't admit that uh I
pretty much admitted the evidence shows
Joe Biden lied to the American people
when he said he had never spoken to any
of these people about uh anything where
Joe Biden was meeting with these people
we have emails we have text messages we
have pictures we have travel logs we
have travel records we have sworn
testimony from Devin Archer who was
front and thinner in a couple of these
shell companies that Joe Biden
communicated with these people in fact
communicated with every single person
who wired the Biden millions and
millions of dollars he even had dinner
on more than one occasion with these
individuals which we didn't know so Joe
Biden live when he said his family never
got money while he was vice president he
lied when he said his family never got
money from China and he lied when he
said he never communicated with any of
these Crooks who were sending his family
the millions and millions of dollars so
we've proven over and over again that
Joe Biden lied what I think the evidence
shows is Joe Biden was front and center
in this from day one Devin Archer said
what they were doing because we want to
know what did they do to receive the
millions and millions of dollars Devin
Archer said they were telling the brand
yeah and the brand was Joe Biden
Congressman will you commit tonight to
calling David Weiss
to testify before Congress despite this
appointment absolutely of course we will
we're not going to stop this is just
another day in the office for us uh
leading this investigation of Biden
corruption they have obstructed every
step of the way they've intimidated our
Witnesses look when Devin Archer was set
to come in on Monday morning the doj
sent him a letter Saturday and a letter
again Sunday that's never happened
before never has the Department of
Justice sent a letter on a weekend and
they sent two on two separate days for
the sole purpose of intimidating him
they have intimidated every one of our
Witnesses the Biden legal team Abby
Lowell and Company they have more than
crossed the line of witness intimidation
uh you saw what what the legal team did
in the Delaware Court trying to
intimidate another person to take
something off the website there's
examples
but Laura we're going to continue to
move forward with this investigation
but yeah the question is what are they
trying to hide and you know trying to I
think everyone knows what this is I mean
even if there's not a check that went to
Joe Biden whether expenses were covered
for his home or he's just happy his son
is getting all this money I mean we all
kind of know what this is but
Congressman we look forward to that
testimony and he's going to give you the
Heisman not going to do it but we're
gonna we'll look forward to it anyway
Congress and thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else